[Music]
the idea of a test bed in the university
context is doing a research project that
has a practical application on campus
I'm working to look at MIT as a system
and map all of our material consumption
I'm providing information to MIT by
studying MIT
one of the aspects of my research is
doing waste audits taking a bunch of
waste that's been freshly generated and
sorting it by material type and weighing
each of those categories from where I
sit the sustainability vector has a
positive direction and we have lots of
opportunities to influence that vector
and put it in have magnitude and impact
we have the opportunity to invent the
way we not only build the buildings but
also our open space
we are also with the power plan and our
distribution systems rethinking how we
provide energy and with the analytics in
place there's a lot of room for analysis
critique and learning this whole idea of
campus as a testament is very very
exciting the Koshien plant is right
outside my window I can see all the
water just getting wasted of the cooling
towers
it'll be the first power plants in the
world to use this really amazing
technology and have an impact of the
water footprint of the campus
the campus itself becoming a testbed
helps the Entrepreneurship spirit of the
campus by providing these pilots and
de-risking the technology and it helps
us really reach our sustainability goals
what we saw was a call for action from
president rife back in October 2015 that
really kicked us off and accelerated
these testbed environments mi t--'s
climate action plan creates a new
low-carbon energy centers within the MIT
Energy Initiative each one of those
centers is focused on a different
low-carbon technology area energy
storage advanced solar advanced nuclear
nuclear fusion it calls for a new
environment and sustainability minor the
first time ever that MIT will be
offering a comprehensive sustainability
minor a 32% reduction and campus
emissions by 2030 at least I mean we see
that as a floor we hope to do much
better than that our goal with sandbox
really is to help students in every way
possible connect to the right ecosystem
that can help them accelerate their
ideas and we have about 30 projects that
can fit into sustainability we're doing
some incredible work on low carbon
technology here and it will be
indispensable to solving the climate
problem but I'd say it's necessary and
not sufficient this is a problem it's
gonna require all of us contributing to
it so you know that means social change
behavioral change but really getting
everybody involved in being part of the
solution of the problem
[Music]
you